just been chilling in vegas this whole
time yeah yeah
yep it came back though uh
yeah i just uh i like it in vegas man i
came back but i don't want to that's
your hood i want to leave
you want you want to go back to
basically i want to go back yeah i love
it you love it you would love it
yeah i need to go out there oh you did
yeah on jones
what jones i didn't know that way you
live out there
oh when you're boxing with me that's
where my nephew lives
jones jones in the uh 95. oh he's about
he's a suburban yeah
but but you're you're by wearing jumping
no
i didn't have a hood right now i don't
know how they changed it
are you really promising i don't think
the dorms in warren springs
oh that yeah that's nice you're kind of
far out from the like the strip or
something yeah yeah yeah like when
i when people think vegas they're
brandon
well i don't know if you're doing
residency or something [ __ ] like
you know what i'm saying
is
my first tattoo in the trash bro yeah no
it wasn't nice it was
like he was i didn't know i it was like
some hood stuff let's see
yeah which one this one right here i
don't even know what it says oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't look like
amazing it looks like it says available
it says two things yes like life and
death tattoo that myth man has
exactly no that one so it says loyalty
and what else and it's supposed to say
family if i do like this
oh no no it doesn't help and you gotta
get there
no just add to it
it looks like it says available yeah it
looks like it says available and you
turn around
let's see look so this is the l this is
the l right here right and that's the o
i can see the y the y is this is
probably okay you see the a
okay that's why that's where you lost me
okay well it looks like
about this way do you see family this
way absolutely not no
no because that looks like a m all right
is there any way you can say
i was in the stratosphere what do you
want me to do that was like true yeah so
did you go on the rides after or what
yeah yeah i did it i loved i
like i said i love vegas i i love vegas
you do how long did you live out there
for uh for three years
yeah what were you doing out there
boxing with floyd mayweather and his job
nice i uh vegas is triggering for me
you're gonna make fun of me vegas the
trigger
for me because that's where like when i
had really big fights like at mandalay
bay
mgm it was so intense there yeah and
then i did the ultimate fighter there so
it's like the memories there like
it's so intense yeah so when i did a
show that uh some casino there
and when i touched down it's like ah
it's like so it's so triggering for me
so you might be triggering like ptsd yes
oh really gonna get real tense
really such a tendency you're there for
fights it's for really
serious [ __ ] you was focused the whole
time when you're like getting an
ultimate
fighter so you say you really was just
focused you were in the house so you
can't really go anywhere
i'm ultimate fighter it was like a covet
what is that like man being in a house
where everyone wants to fight
uh you know what i mean like everyone
wants to fight you know even the one
that
like you you hang out with yeah
everybody that's gonna
fight soon like i had boys in the house
like we were close but then you're
fighting you know they're they only
uh kind of reward two guys in the house
so you make to the finale
you get a career so it's like i have 16
guys two guys are really going to make
it
yeah so you're in this house and it was
like my big break though so i was
chomping at i was
it was just all but i was like six weeks
all you gotta do is get through this for
six weeks and i need a career sign me
the [ __ ] up man
yeah and i remember like we the everyone
the first night everyone's in the hot
tub everyone's like
talking about what they're what they
want to do in the house i just remember
one guy going
i just hope i win like one or two fights
and he was like one of the most
talented dudes he's like i should buy
win one or two fights i remember
thinking my head i'm going to fight him
first
yeah so the next day i went to my coach
give me that guy goes no dude let's save
him let's save him for later in the
rounds
i'm telling you i'll beat the shot of
that guy he's not here for the right
reasons
so you could it's it's weird like you
could there's mental games you could
figure out who was like who's the real
deal who was it like off the bat
off the bat i didn't know just walking
into that house is already a chess match
yeah like before you even get to the
ring yeah i didn't see a lot of people
wouldn't
even notice that oh yeah you ever just
go into an environment and you just feel
tension right like there was a lot of
shit's about to happen all the time that
that was your house right it was that
all the time and then
guys started losing and because it is a
reality show
right it's like the real world mix with
mixed martial arts uh
so those guys who were losing they would
give them all the alcohol they could
handle
so i'm there to get a contract they're
there to just they they're out they're
out of the race but they made them stay
in the house
what and so they just got hammered oh
the producers did that oh yeah so they
would get
kind of hammered and then the rest of us
were trying to stay focused so it's like
this weird
mind [ __ ] oh weird why'd they keep them
in the house because it's a great kind
of drama
and then also because you broke up in
two teams teams of eight
so you would need training partners to
get ready for the fight so they want
them to stay in the house
oh and it got weird man like one dude
got really hammered started like shh
chanting racist [ __ ] there's black guys
in the house
what did the black that's the kimbo
slice story yeah he's like yeah he wakes
me up he goes hey man
which one calls talking about our people
i was like i was like sleeping because i
had a big fight the next day and i'm
like what
i was like i thought i was dreaming kim
was like yo man because i wake up to a
bunch of black guys i'm sleeping on the
floor yeah it's kimbo
marcus jones and d'amico rogers three
black guys wait a way to wake up yeah
and they're like yo man they're talking
about our people
and i was like the [ __ ] is he talking
about and he goes they're talking about
our [ __ ] people wake up shop
i'm like doc i'm not black he goes
you're not
was kimbo in the race or was he
eliminated uh at this point they
they've they [ __ ] kimbo because um he
was such a big name
they wanted him to lose right away and
it was they did
they did him such a disservice they they
should have melted him
and and really helped them out but they
[ __ ] them over why would they do that
because they wanted to make like prove
that he wasn't the real deal which he
was he was a great dude
and like a real fighter he was there for
the right reasons he didn't need to be
there he was set financially yeah he
just wanted to test himself
so they were like oh kimbo you're the
youtuber you ain't a real fighter you're
not a pro
so his first fight they paired him up
with the guy who was a former world
champion over 30 fights
black belt and jiu-jitsu just a
nightmare for kimbo like he didn't have
a [ __ ] prayer
yeah they gave him roy nelson he got
destroyed
so he only had one fight and it was so
stupid man he was such a good dude
oh my god such a good person such a
gentle soul and just like
absorbed everything yeah like he you
know he didn't know ground
so he'd come to me and roy nelson and be
like man how do i get better on the
ground what i do here
what he was the best well he was my guy
so
the way i got i dealt with like the
anxiety of the house i just go talk to
him
because he was older than me and he has
all that like history and yeah
he he he uh he was really good at
barbecuing
so he'd come up with his own barbecue
sauce and then he would tell me about
like he was like job if you're gonna
fight man
he's like you give him and they have a
knife give him your arm and i was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and he goes look give me your arm he
shows me his forearm and he has scars
like a great white shark's [ __ ] nose
he has scars on his arm he's like cause
this ain't [ __ ] man you give him that
and then you [ __ ] deck him
i was like right on yeah
the barbecue done the barbecue
no no you know what i pissed yeah are we
making
ribs i'm sorry i don't want the brisket
to get burnt
that's fantastic
for the burgers i'm sorry are you
thirsty because i'm gonna
i'm gonna get out of here
hey man he fights with nine
what
his barbecue was ridiculous so the we me
and him would just
make up plans to start a barbecue chain
when he got out
oh man really slice his barbecue that's
hard though how did you pass
uh i think he had a heart attack ah
something happened where he needed like
a transplant like a heart
and he couldn't get him out are you
going to see his movie they have a movie
coming out about uh kimbo slice
really yeah
yeah like a movie theater oh yeah you
know what i loved about him man is that
[ __ ] hair bro
like he gave zero [ __ ] that he had the
sherman hemsley yeah
like real like fight enthusiasts give me
[ __ ] for this but he should be on the
mount rushmore fighting
because if you think about it like the
way i got introduced to
fighting like mixed martial arts it was
him on youtube
yeah like you remember going to youtube
and he looks exactly how you would pick
yeah if you made a video game of a
backyard brawler it'd be a jumbo slice
[ __ ] dudes up and then you're like oh
my god that guy's scary then you meet
him like holy [ __ ] he's the nicest guy
in the house
yeah he's also the most genuine great
dude
wow he didn't have a mean bone in his
body look at that man
yeah and like a family man yeah like but
you look at the outside and you think oh
you know oh yeah kids and stuff yeah
[ __ ] yeah
his son fights in bellator this weekend
you know what's crazy too is no one
really watches that backyard [ __ ]
anymore there was something about
this right yeah it was so like you
really felt like you were watching
a real fight yeah like it was like it
wasn't or no but it wasn't
organized it looked like chaotic this
[ __ ] happened in the backyard of
someone's house yeah
but that's exactly what happened well it
was yeah you don't want to say it was
organized but
with the dress
was not this he was dope yeah he's great
when they sent him in to fight that dude
in the white shirt
crazy because the white shorts was no
joke
did you but there there was a
documentary on netflix about backyard
fighting with dota 5000
oh yeah i remember i watched that one
they're still doing it really
well they're still doing it yeah a lot
of [ __ ] still happens in miami it's huge
it's big enough
it's big yeah and then dota 5000 was
kind of like the
kimbo slice of like uh was it dade
county
he was kind of the kimbo slice there and
for whatever reason you know
he wanted to fight kimbo he did and they
fought oh they did well what happened
it was the worst professional fight i've
ever seen in my life really
because you know because they're
backyard fighters dude it's just
it's just different yeah they were tired
so it should like kimbo actually
brought a professional uh mindset to it
and then dota 5000 it's like you know he
has titties and just like
and you know how when i go but did you
die yeah dada died
he died and they brought him back to
life he was so exhausted
life and that's why about
dota 5000 died inside that gun and then
there was ambulance to the side brought
him back to life
wait wait what and did he get back in
for the next round i think he died in
the hospital for a little bit and then
came back to life yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay i thought like in the
ring it was like hold on you got one
more round
did you die he's like yeah i did yeah
wow did you die yeah i did
it was one of the worst fights you've
ever seen in your life because that's
really out
but he but but him like in the backyard
he's a beast no one wanted to [ __ ] with
him
you know in the backyard yeah but then
you bring it to the professional level
it's just a dip it's just
different ballpark he has no business
being in this yeah
but a ton of people watched it really
yeah
watch that fight the ufc really [ __ ]
up with kimbo he he could
they could have done so much more with
him and released him to like
to just like be the face and get more
kids involved with it and like
his story is so good he's a fan so
you're saying they should have set him
up with like easier fights instead of
putting it
not even easier but don't give them the
progressive
like the worst match like the ultimate
fighter they now it's the
they're going to bring back the ultimate
fight but there's the contender series
now dana white's
tuesday night fights yeah those are
young upcoming fighters
who if they do well they get a ufc
contract that's like their new feeder
league now
yeah but that's what the ultimate
fighter is for it's like guys like me
i'd
i think four fights when i went in the
house like like roy nelson should have
been on that show
he had over 30 fights former world
champion like he should be guys like me
kimbo slice
d'amico rogers like guys who are
learning the process and trying to get
through then
you got roy nelson who's a world champ
performer i mean i thought
uh andre alofski ben rothwell like we're
just like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah did he win that one he wanted
he ended up beating me in the finals
he lives in vegas now right yeah yeah he
just got i think he got uh really
he was fighting in bellator he had a
rough you know run there but
uh yeah i think they just got him but
he's a vegas guy also
great dude yeah smart guy too man yeah
when you can uh
when you can eat someone alive you're
usually just nice about it
yeah nothing's really serious you
understand your power yeah
i mean i'm with you yeah but some of
them are dicks you know how it goes like
some of them just
it's like their ego like they still
don't realize they don't realize it no a
lot of some of them don't most of them
are great
but there's still some that want to make
sure you know they're the toughest guy
in the bar
what are you doing i don't like hanging
out with that guy it's like hanging out
with a comic you know yeah you know
maybe they're not doing well and they're
constantly just it's like dude you don't
not everything's a joke yeah just chill
the [ __ ] out man yeah man we don't need
it all the time yeah you don't need us
in the conversation yeah no you're doing
a bit
right yeah don't start any of your
sentences with uh
you ever uh yeah hey i don't want to
talk to anyone that's at the bar going
hey you ever uh yeah hey you're being
walmart
yeah no dude but it's the same thing
with like
you know the difference between like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son